days Dalai Lama has some fantastic sweet
options for you we are joined by best
friends since middle school Charlene
Davis and Leah Garrett of Dalai Lama
which I love that story I want to get to
that in a second but let's talk about
what you guys have you're across from
UNLV is that right and this is something
you've been doing since September of
this year right yes sir so tell people
who don't know about Dalai Lama what
you're all about
Dalai Lama is a franchise out of LA and
we brought it here to Vegas so it's we
specialize in two different kind of
waffles the bubble waffle and the OG
liaise waffle ice cream and milkshakes
and it looks good by the way these
waffles these are not your Eggos right
these are true bells and Waffles I
understand that the uh founder of Dalai
Lama sent chefs to Belgium to learn how
to make these yes he did and they
perfected them and crafted them and came
up with the Dalai Lama brand he actually
knew a llama that he met in Europe
called named Dolly oh that's so cool and
I love the fact that you guys have been
best friends for so long since middle
school here in Las Vegas yes that's so
cool and when did you what made you
decide to do this together
um a Instagram post so it was advertised
on Instagram and I said it looks good
and we flew to LA and tried it and loved
it and you've loved it so much you're
not only opening this one you're opening
one in Texas as well right and four more
in Vegas wow congratulations when are
those gonna be up and running one every
year that's fantastic man you guys are a
great success story all right I'm so
excited to try which one of these do you
want me to try so let's do our holiday
signature right now okay it's our
holiday mint chip ice cream with
chocolate sauce it has a little
marshmallow Snowman on it with some
ropes and I think you should try that I
love it do we have any spoons
okay I'll get some spoons we'll get some
spoons because I'm going to be sampling
a lot of this uh what can people also
look forward to enjoying at your place
at Dalai Lama we have a few Classics our
Dolly's Dream It's with our Cookie
Monster ice cream it's a blue vanilla
ice cream with cookie dough graham
crackers and Oreos so it's here and then
we have another one which is a classic
it's on our OG waffle that would be our
llama gone knits it's vanilla ice cream
with peanut butter sauce almonds and
bananas oh man so delicious and all low
in calories right yes yes
we don't need to worry about that we're
indulging I absolutely love that you're
doing this and that you are such a great
success story and that there are more
coming to Las Vegas in the next few
years we're excited yeah good luck with
all of this thank you what's your
favorite what's your personal favorite
mine would be the Dolly's dream okay
Dolly's dream mine is the sugar and
spice we don't have it up here right now
but it's horchata ice cream with
Cinnamon Toast Crunch and speculo's
cookies and caramel sauce oh my gosh I'm
gonna be checking out the first one
already open across from UNLV what's the
address 4632 South Maryland Parkway
Suite 112. I'm a university Gardens
fantastic hey congratulations thank you
I love stories like yours